oh my goodness, look at this.
As long as we're here, you know, one of the things that's
fun about Macworld is it's really an iFan event.
And great people, great friends are here.
Old friend Sal Segoian, I know many of you
recognize him from the Mac breaks he did.
I'm a big fan of yours.
Oh, you are?
Oh, I'm a total fan.
I am an addict of your shows.
I sit there with the live stream on all the time.
Sal.
When I'm working, the last thing I see
before I fall asleep at night is I watch Leo.
Oh, aren't you sweet?
So you're actually not doing anything for Apple here.
your guitar. Yes, I'm here as a musician. I'm performing tomorrow, Friday, at 1230 in the
music studio, which is a really lovely area right upstairs. And Performing what? I play solo Midi
Guitar I've been playing music since I was 16. I'm a graduate of the Berklee College of Music.
No kidding. I want my kid to go there. Can you help him? No, really, seriously, that's a great
school in Boston. Not in Berklee, ironically. I graduated in 79, so I started in 74 there.
And some of the guys that graduated were like, you know, Kevin Eubanks and those guys, Ralph Moore, were my peers in those days.
Still one of the greatest music schools in the world.
If you had money you were in, whether you could stay or not, that was totally up to you.
You had to earn your way.
Yeah, you had to earn your way.
So, how many Macworlds have you been to?
You know, I know probably as many as you.
20 or something.
Yeah, something like that, yeah.
I couldn't count them.
I'm like a dinosaur looking for a tar pit when it comes to Macworlds.
It's still a little bit of a buzz when you know it's Macworld Day and you're going to get to come here and see the people.
It's mostly about people at this point.
I really agree.
I think it's very much about the relationships that we establish among the community with each other,
catching up, discussing Trends looking at materials, ideas, software, the future.
And it gives that kind of interaction that you can only get at a live event
and actually getting out and coming here.
That really makes the difference.
We'll still need these so that we can get together and face-to-face and hear music.
And you know who else is here? Myra Joyce is here. Come here, Myra, because Myra throws us a cocktail party every year at Macworld. Right, Myra?
That's right. It is tonight, 6 o'clock.
Are you going to come to Intercontinental Hotel?
Uh-oh. I'm there.
Say the secret word. I'll buy you a drink.
I think we have a couple of secret passwords. Thank you for putting that on for us, Myra.
It's my pleasure. Yeah, I'll see you later.
It's going to be a lot of fun.
Sal, great to see you, too. Say hi to Naomi.
thank you, and thank you for your continued support of the Mac Community
We really appreciate it, man.
You're great.
You're outstanding.
Thanks.
Sousa Goyan, everybody.
See ya.
Are you ready to go inside?
Let's see Macworld Expo.